REALLY HAPPY NEW YEAR'S.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Ed: ALSO TONIGHT, CHIEF
REPUBLICAN NUMBER OF THE
REPUBLICAN HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
THANKS FOR COMING IN.
HEARING VICTOR LAID OUT OUT,
THEY SUGGESTED YOU CAN'T BEAT
DONALD TRUMP AT THE BATTLE OF
THE BOX AND 2020 AND YOU HAVE TO
IMPEACH HIM.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOW THE ECONOMY
SLOWING OUT THIS WEEK AND HOW
THE IMPEACHMENT DRAMA WAS
PLAYING OUT, YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> VERY STRANGE AND ALSO YOU SEE
THE IMPEACHMENT DID NOT REALLY
SERVE AS THE SUBSTITUTE FOR THE
AGENDA FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE NOT BEEN FOR
MAILING THEIR COMMITMENTS ON
TRADE, HEALTH CARE, THE ECONOMY
AND SOAP IMPEACHMENT HAS REALLY
BEEN THE ALTERNATIVE TO THAT AND
IT'S ALL BEEN CONSUMING AS THE
OBSESSION.
IF IT'S A LITTLE BIT BIZARRE TO
HEARKEN BACK TO A FEW WEEKS TO
THAT WHEN ERIC SWALWELL CALLED
THE PRESIDENTS CONDUCT A CRIME
SPREE IN PROCESS.
IF NOTHING WAS MORE URGENT THEN
NANCY PELOSI IS JUST SITTING ON
THE IMPEACHMENT ARTICLES IN THE
EGG THAT SHE'S WAITING TO HATCH
AT ANY MOMENT.
>> Ed: IF THERE'S A CRIME
SPREE, WHY HAVE THE ARTICLES NOT
BEEN SENT TO THE SENATE SO THE
PRESIDENT CAN BE BROUGHT TO A
TRIAL?
>> THAT'S ALL BEASLEY THE
CONTRADICTION THAT WE CAN SEE
FROM THE DEMOCRATS, AND IT'S
HARD TO TAKE FIERCELY AS HE
POINTED OUT AND YOU HAD
DEMOCRATS WITH RACHEL MADDOW
TRYING TO READ THE INTO A
DOSSIER THAT WE'VE BEEN TELLING
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WAS FALSE.
THE DEMOCRATS AND THE ALLIES AND
IMMEDIATE WERE WRONG ON TWO
FRONTS.
IF ONE, THE UNDERLYING VERACITY
OR TRUTH OF THE DOSSIER AND THAT
STEALS SOME SORT OF SOURCES AND
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE TELL THEM,
WIDE DID NOT END UP IN A
DOCUMENT?
THE DOSSIER WAS USED, YOU HAVE
RACHEL MADDOW, ADAM SCHIFF,
SAYING THE FBI DID NOTHING WRONG
TO LEAVE FOLLOWED THE PFIZER
PROCESS AND WE SEE THAT DOSSIER
WAS CENTRAL PART.
>> Ed: ONE THING FOR THE MEDIA
TO BE CALLED OUT AND HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND WE ALL MAKE
THEM.
THIS WAS A BIG ONE.
IF YOU GO BEYOND THAT, AND I'M
SURE IF YOU INVOKED A MOMENT
AGO, HE WENT MUCH FURTHER HE'S
IN THE CONGRESS AND BEEN ELECTED
BY
PEOPLE IN THE DISTRICT AS YOU
KNOW AND HE'S THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE VERY POWERFUL COMMITTEE.
IT BEGINS AT 2017 WITH RACHEL
MADDOW INTERVIEWING ADAM SCHIFF
AND HE SORT OF SIDESTEPS THE
QUESTION OF THE VERACITY OF THE
DOSSIER AS YOU KNOW AND WE KNOW
NOW, THE ADAM SCHIFF MEMO WAS
FALSE.
THE VERY POWERFUL COMMITTEE TO A
HIGHER STANDARD.
>> ABSOLUTELY, YOU REMEMBER WHEN
DEVIN NUNES PUT OUT THE MEMO AND
ADAM SCHIFF PUT UP THE RESPONSE,
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA SAY, OH,
THE MEMO HAS BEEN DEBUNKED AND
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY THE TRUTH.
IF WE NOW HAVE SOMETHING WE
RARELY GET AN WASHINGTON
POLITICS AND ACTUALLY IT IN FORH
POLITICS AND ACTUALLY IT IN FORE
RESULTS FROM THE OBAMA POINT OF
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL SAYING
THAT DEVIN NUNES WAS RIGHT ALL
THE TIME, ADAM SCHIFF WAS WRONG.
THERE'S INTELLIGENCE AS THE
ARMED SERVICE COMMITTEE MEMBER
THAT I CANNOT SEE BUT I HAVE TO
RELY ON WITH ADAM SCHIFF AND THE
GANG TO CORRECTLY ASSESS THAT
INTELLIGENCE AND GIVE UP THE
ACCURATE PERCEPTIONS.
THAT ADAM SCHIFF SHOULD BE
REMOVED AS THE CHAIRMAN SO WE
CAN AT LEAST GET CLEAR EYES ON
THE MOST IMPORTANT INTELLIGENCE
ANALYSIS IN THE COUNTRY.
AT >> Ed: 'S CLUSTERING,
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" HAD A
PIECE SUGGESTING THAT
NANCY PELOSI WANTS TO ROLL THE
IMPEACHMENT THAT SHE'S HOLDING
THE ARTICLES WAITING FOR
SOMEBODY ELSE TO DRAW.
JUST HANGING IT OVER THE
PRESIDENTS HEAD FOR THE ELECTION
GRADE OF YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> THEY'RE BECOMING THE ONE-HIT
WONDER WHERE IT'S ONLY
IMPEACHMENT AND GOT POSTPARTUM
DEPRESSION BECAUSE THEY BURST
THE IMPEACHMENT OUT AND THE OF
THE TASK THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO LITIGATE ITS, WHAT
STRANGE BUT POLITICALLY MORE
THAT THEY TALK ABOUT THE
IMPEACHMENT AND OPENING
HEARINGS, THE WORSE THINGS GET
FOR THEM.
THE CLEAR POLITICS PULLING
AVERAGING OUR INVERTED IT WHEN
DEMOCRATS STARTED HOLDING PUBLIC
HEARING BECAUSE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE GET TO SEE HOW THIN THEIR
CASE WAS.
THEY SHOULD BE THROUGH WITH THIS
AND WE SHOULD ALL HAVE A
NEW YEAR'S RESOLUTION TO BE DONE
WITH IMPEACHMENT AND THE
INVESTIGATIONS AND LET'S
ACTUALLY PUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
FIRST.